[Music]
do you even remember what you did this
weekend yeah what'd you do why went to a
wedding why I'm just genuinely trying to
remember for myself
yeah it took me a second but uh it was
kind of a whirlwind but um we went to a
wedding in San Clemente and uh weddings
are something
wedding like is like goes along with the
things that I'm scared to do sober
because it's like
I don't know how much of how much fun a
[ __ ] wedding I don't know it's
recovery day dude Jesus Christ
go ahead uh no it's fine no no it's fine
no I want to hear it
because like bars suck it sucks to be in
a bar sober like they're it's just
engineered for people that are drinking
that's the only scenario it's fun yes a
wedding kind of Falls in that same sort
of basket yeah a lot like I'm kind of
socializing I was kind of dreading it a
little bit but uh
ended up just having the best time and I
realized like weddings really aren't
engineered it's just like alcohol kind
of elevates everything but it really is
a blast on its own yeah like just seeing
people you haven't seen in a long time
like a lot of people from college that I
had seen in like 12 years
um to some dancing or ten years I guess
yeah the music was incredible they had a
DJ with a live saxophone player like
combined yeah so it was like half banned
half like recorded old music yeah it
just felt good like felt good to you
know wake up the next day and I feel
like us yeah what'd you do I'm trying to
or just wedding plan stuff wedding
planning I like
bought a bunch of clothes for it
I can't even
oh I told you we did the courthouse like
a couple weeks ago oh yeah so you're
officially
you're officially married yeah damn dude
we lost another good one
yeah how's it feel to have a ball and
chain
the same
nah I ripped ass in the kitchen this
morning and she was like in the other
room she just shouts out that was
disgusting I was like I held that [ __ ]
in for 11 years yeah we're married now
[ __ ]
you're stuck I'll let a couple more ago
I just had to be in Fletchling
disgusting
it's a funny thing to find out about
your partner after you get married yeah
that they're just really gassy yeah
waited 11 years to show what's up
[Music]
that's sick so how's it feel
the same yeah no I mean it's got a
different feeling but
I'm kind of excited to say my wife not
like Borat but just say it because it's
a lot easier than Fiona I just said it
like we're out there because it's like a
habit but
the like it's way easier to say wife
than fiance yeah yeah my wife did my
fiance had five syllables I hate saying
fiance Beyonce he did this I hate
Beyonce because
people then like strangers want to spark
up conversation about when we're gonna
get married yeah oh and they'd start
doing this interviewing [ __ ] and I'm
like I just yeah
how'd you guys meet yeah
I just want to [ __ ] buy my [ __ ] and
go that is the worst thing about wedding
planning yeah is that you spend
hours focused on this task of planning
your wedding and then when you're done
you go see family and it's all they ask
you about is yes that and you're like oh
no we just finished talking we just
finished the focus on that
and no more yeah we just want to talk
about other things now they're like so
how is everything going did you find the
thing yeah that's all family does how's
it going yeah do you need help yeah yeah
you want to like pick up
yeah
now our I mean our families have offered
it to help but like we do have a wedding
planner yeah and she's been good too it
goes through waves where it's just like
I have a [ __ ] ton to do in this one week
and then all of a sudden you don't have
[ __ ] to do for two weeks yeah our
wedding planner she you know she's good
but
it's like she's in a foreign country
there's always like time differences and
Elena just cannot wait is in if she
wants to get something done she's like
I'm not I'm not about to wait for the
time zone to catch up so she'll just be
wake up at two in the morning doing tons
of emails like getting info waking up at
eight being like all right they
responded I gotta get this [ __ ] in I'm
like
I don't want to do this yeah but now
it's been it's been fun I'm stoked yeah
it's been
you find a videographer to shoot it yeah
like a wedding one or did you hire
someone no we didn't okay let's go a
standard wedding
like I'm saying but it's just kind of
funny it's like we oh so own a
production company it's like we could we
could do this I'm looking at the prices
of the for these people and I'm like I
yeah this is like kind of we our
specialty is making videos yeah you know
but then again it's a wedding video it's
a whole different type of genre you
don't even and it's also like I don't
want to be in the weeds of that like no
I don't even want to think about it I'm
gonna be directing on your wedding I
know exactly I mean can you get a shot
of my family yeah let's reset on the
cake yeah great let's just a little bit
more around yeah you may not kiss the
bride yeah can we reset on that yeah one
of the people that we met with one of
the videographers this [ __ ] is crazy
is Kanye West drone guy he's Kanye West
drone guy now he's married to Kanye West
no he was shooting this wedding he was
telling us the story he sent me the shot
afterwards it's [ __ ] crazy he was
shooting this wedding
and he had a drone shot of the Bride
walking down the groom or walking down
the groom walking down the aisle damn on
top of the groom it's crazy weird
wedding walking down the aisle and as
they walked down this fairy this super
huge big ugly Ferry drives through like
whatever Channel they were getting
married in front of like a big big ass
boat
right it's like honking and people are
like tourists are like ah waving and
[ __ ] like that and he comps it out in
the final video oh well he just took a
play shot of the thing without the boat
in it and then comp that I was like damn
that is impressive yeah
but it's a lie
I know what really happened
tell us the truth yeah yeah I thought
about
doing like
some funny [ __ ] with the final edit
giving him notes he's going to make it
all cute and whatever and I thought
about just giving him notes to make it
as a trailer okay two people this summer
yeah yeah
this fall two people from different
parts of life Meet the Millers
we just got him shooting scenes on the
day oh yeah he's just like all right
this is gonna be a quick insert I was
gonna do a quick wardrobe change then
we'll get back into the you know the
[ __ ] and then he's just like what the
[ __ ] are we doing yeah we were joking
after the courthouse because obviously
we've been together for so long
we were you know people would see it so
congratulations I'm like I know we ended
it
yeah like Lena's joking like just
telling people yeah we just got divorced
yeah yeah
Elena went to the dentist
and she talked about the podcast a
little bit but she the person goes
oh your boyfriend was in here the other
day
and she goes no he's actually my
just left it
and she said she didn't want the first
time for her to say husband my husband
to be at the dentist so she just opted
to stop talking
and then the dentist was like working on
her teeth like yes we're not talking
about yeah yeah yeah I'm just dying
laughing at her in the chair just be
like oh no that's my
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no well if you want to
hear about 911 I want to hear about
husbands then
you don't want to say husband then you
want to hear about my husband that did
911 then did 9 11. that's funny so where
is what's the ideal place to save my
husband for the first time I don't I
mean that's a great question for her
she should she should have said my hubby
he's actually my hubby wubby
those feel bad